Speaker 1: Our friend Michael Cohen, Donald
Trump's former personal attorney, he seems
to be putting his foot down and saying, hey,
guys, either indict Trump or I'm out and I'm
going to stop cooperating.
And I have to tell you, I sympathize with
Michael Cohen 100%.
So let's go through what's going on.
There's a good Daily Beast piece called The
Manhattan DA's Star Witness Indict Trump Now
or I'm Out the Pieces by Jose Pagliaro.
And it reads, If Manhattan prosecutors don't
indict former President Donald Trump with
the grand jury they've got in the next nine
days, the key witness investigators used to
build their entire case says he won't help
revive it in the future.
They're talking, of course, about Michael
Cohen, the New York lawyer Trump used for
years as his family's as his family company's
trusted consiglieri, told The Daily Beast
he's already wasted too much of his time on
a case that slowly and then suddenly doesn't
seem to be going anywhere.
Prosecutors only have until the current grand
jury's term expires on April 30 to issue charges,
at which point they must ask jurors who have
already done this for six months to continue
hearing evidence or call the whole thing off
and awkwardly, make the entire presentation
all over again for another 23 jurors.
If this grand jury is let go, Cohen won't
play ball.
Asked if he'd be willing to sit down again
with investigators or testify at a future
trial against Trump, Cohen responded with
utter exasperation.
Now, I've spent countless hours, 15 sessions,
including three while incarcerated.
I provided thousands of documents which, coupled
with my testimony, would have been a valid
basis for an indictment and charge the fact
that they have not done so.
Despite all of this, I'm not interested in
any further investment of my time.
I have to tell you, this makes perfect, perfect
sense.
Now, some people are mad at Michael Cohen
saying, wait a second, you have the knowledge,
you have the information.
Hell, you're the one who actually was found
guilty of crimes related to doing Trump's
bidding and now you're going to bail.
But this makes 100% sense to me.
Remember, we have now learned about the resignation
of investigators in an investigation into
Donald Trump.
Why did the investigators resign?
They resigned because they saw that there
was enough evidence not only to charge Trump,
but they felt to clearly get convictions.
And yet it didn't seem to them like there
was actually any political interest in bringing
forth charges against Donald Trump.
Why are you sitting around doing this type
of work if it's not going to go anywhere?
There is a torture technique and or it's just
a way to kind of make people exasperated.
Right.
And we've heard about this a lot.
When we talk about hard labor in prison over
time in history, sometimes one thing that
was done is you just have people break rocks
and then move them and then move them back.
And knowing that what you're doing is going
to go absolutely nowhere is absolutely demoralizing.
And so I understand the investigators saying,
what are we just doing this for fun?
Is this just an academic exercise?
Because there seems to be no willingness to
actually charge Donald Trump.
They resigned and Michael Cohen seems to be
feeling something pretty similar.
I've given you everything.
I testified while incarcerated.
I've provided documents.
I'm give you hell.
I got in trouble for the stuff that Trump
directed me to do, which was against the law.
And it's going nowhere.
And the grand jury is set to end on April
30th.
So this is very clearly one of the most blatant
political non prosecutions that I've seen
in the world of national American politics.
Cohen is at this point understandably exasperated.
Multiple people around Trump have gone to
prison for crimes they did either for or in
coordination with Trump.
We've had multiple investigations.
What what are we doing?
We've seen campaign finance violations.
We've seen obstruction.
We've seen the removal and mishandling of
classified documents.
We arguably have seen election fraud, conspiracy
in.
Minimum in the state of Georgia.
And these are just the obvious ones.
Let's not even talk about the multiple conspiracies
elsewhere.
The rest of America, I think, is now seeing
the disenfranchisement that so many groups
have felt for a long time.
Right.
I mean, the non-rich know about the two justice
systems.
Minorities know about being treated in a particular
way by police.
Jews and Muslims know about religious discrimination.
Remember, in the United States, when we look
at religious hate crimes, it's Jews and Muslims
that are primarily targeted.
We now are all seeing exactly how this plays
out.
So he gets treated one way and everybody else
gets treated a different way.
Yep, that's exactly what's going on.
So I as much as the next guy would want to
see charges brought.
But I understand why Michael Cohen is putting
his foot down, how much more of his life has
to be devoted to testifying and giving evidence
and having lawyers himself.
Remember when it's not even clear that there's
really a willingness to bring charges.
So we'll see what happens.
There's three more days until this grand jury
is done and then we'll see what happens after
that.